good afternoon thank you all for joining
us for the Silicon Valley HDX panel my
name is Wolfgang neared I'll be your
moderator this afternoon I always like
to take a moment to thank the folks that
make this festival free fun and
fantastic and those are the folks you've
seen all day and all weekend long in the
red shirts please help me in thanking
the horrible volunteers in a moment I'll
introduce our two authors today that
you've come to hear so much from I just
want to make a couple of housekeeping
announcements we'll spend a few minutes
with each author briefly discussing
their book in particular than I'd like
to get the two of them Ashley and Kevin
in conversation about the broader topic
of innovation and creativity will
certainly save plenty of time for Q&A
afterwards I would ask that you answer
your questions when we have that time
and then right as soon as we're done
I'll take Kevin and Ashley over to the
book signing tent there'll be at table
21
so I'll encourage you to pick up a hard
copy of their books how to fly a horse
and Elon Musk and I'm sure they'll be
good enough to assign them I hope maybe
take a photograph or a volunteer for a
baptism or Bar Mitzvah and I do
encourage you though did you purchase
the book through our Barnes & Noble
partner they're very very generous in
giving a portion of the proceeds back to
the Texas Book Festival each year which
we certainly appreciate that goes to
fund not only this festival itself but
our year-round Texas Library grants
which helps rural libraries in Texas
cities maintain an a robust system of
programming also for a very limited time
your local library is running a great
great promotion free books so I
encourage you to take advantage of that
and and then they also helped us with
reading rock stars which is a program
where we go to inner-city schools around
Texas have authors read their books to
the students and then in many cases give
the student a hard copy of their book
which is often the only book in that
child's household so very important
stuff so we'll help to see the Barnes &
Noble tent and then a table 21 in the
author book signing 10 so thank you
again for coming let me introduce first
of my left ashley Vance formerly a
reporter for The New York Times now at
Bloomberg Businessweek and also the
author now of the New York Times
bestseller Elon Musk Tesla SpaceX and
the quest for a fantastic future and to
his left
Kevin Ashton
formerly of many many I believe three
technology startups and exits also
co-founder of the auto ID Center MIT and
perhaps most notably known for coining
the term the Internet of Things a
fantastic book how to fly a horse the
secret history of creation invention and
discovery please help me in welcoming
both these gentlemen all right I guess
let me start with Kevin for the very
simple reason that Kevin's book the
preface anyway starts with as all great
stories do the story of a man named
Wolfgang in this case though it was
Mozart and that myself but we'll get
into that another addition but it starts
with Wolfgang Mozart and the book
wonderfully weaves a brilliant narrative
of the historical and contemporary tales
of innovation and really though I got
the sense though of how important
setbacks and and and difficulties were
to these these folks can we at least
start with what was the impetus with the
inspiration for the book originally well
so I I found myself at MIT through a
very kind of random path actually I
I studied Scandinavian studies at
University I know how to read Epson in
19th century Norwegian I was I was hired
by a company called Proctor and Gamble
to launch a range of color cosmetics and
I found myself at MIT and so I felt like
a complete fraud because I was there
leading this group of amazing creative
people and I assumed I guess as many
people do that they were kind of having
ideas in the bathtub and things were
coming to them spontaneously and all my
ideas were the result of trying and
failing and trying and failing so I felt
like a fraud when I first got there it
was about the same time that everyone
was getting into Harry Potter actually
and I kind of felt like I was at
Hogwarts except I wasn't a wizard
then I realized that they weren't doing
any magic they were actually they were
better at it than I was but they were
also trying and failing and going
through a series of steps that people
started asking me to talk about the
creative process and how you innovate
because I was leading something at MIT
and so I started telling the story about
how it wasn't magic it was work and that
really resonated and eventually someone
said you have to write a book about this
and and that's the book very good very
substantial and the book covers
brilliantly many of the historical
thinkers you would think of when you
think of innovation the creative process
for Mozart to to Galileo and Leonardo da
Vinci the Muppets are prominently
featured in this book which I did not
see coming but a happy accident but you
weave so many different they'll have the
similar arc and a similar narrative with
so many different tales just of morbid
curiosity how do the Muppets get in
there and what were some of the other
ways you were able to draw in so many
sources
what do you in the universe of
innovation what how did you decide what
to grab and what to leave in the clouds
um so the big point here is that the way
human beings create is basically the
same no matter what they're creating so
we talked about moats I talked about
Mozart in the book the way you the way
you create a piece of classical music if
you're Mozart is not that different than
where you create Burton Ernie if you're
you know Jim Henson and Frank Oz so by
looking at lots of different apparently
different creative works I think I was
able to show that the fundamental
processes creation are the same no
matter what the discipline and the
stories were in some cases once I
already had Hearst once I was curious
about and you know there's a lot of the
book is about one thing leading to
another and that's also how I came
across some of these stories any of your
own personal background or your personal
experience that mirrors and matches that
whole absolutely I mean my experience is
very much I read some books about what
what people call creativity which is not
a word I like to use as a younger man
and and bought into this myth of genius
and
solving problems without really thinking
about them and aha moments and then
through experience learned that that's
not how it works
and so that informs everything at the
book okay and you really and not only
the history of many thinkers and
creative innovators that we would think
of but this goes back fifty thousand
years literally Hugh touched on the
absolute beginning of Homo sapiens the
evolution and how immediately they began
to to evolve what was what was how did
you draw in that history who did you go
through a sort of an anthropology Trek
or how do you go back that far and what
are they I'm that's something that
really intrigues me is human evolution
and and it's incredibly relevant to the
process of creating this is not
something we hear often enough but the
thing that makes us unique as human
beings is that we have the ability to
improve our tools within our own
lifetime I'll give you an example if you
look at a bird's nest today and a bird's
nest from 20,000 years ago it will be
exactly the same okay there isn't a
meeting going on right now where there's
a bird in a black turtleneck like
striding around on a stage
unveiling bird's nest 6.0 you know it's
thinner and it's faster and it has a
bigger screen so there are quite a few
animals that use tools in fact we're
discovering more and more all the time
but the difference between us and them
is their tools are the product of
instinct and so if their tools change at
all they change as a result of evolution
now human beings have this unique
capability to manipulate symbols I'm
doing it right now right and so are you
I'm using language language is symbolic
the interesting thing about language by
the way is it's actually not primarily
for speaking but for thinking
so we have this ability to imagine and
represent things symbolically manipulate
those symbols and then consider what
might happen if we put these two things
together before we do it and that is
creating so so the ability to be
creative is uniquely an innately human
we all have it which is why we became
this incredible successful species
within the space of about 50,000 years
which is when human beings started
displaying this symbolic representative
tendency and it also is why I can tell
stories about the Muppets and Mozart and
see that they are basically the same we
all have this innate ability to be
creative now it's not equal in everybody
but it is present in everybody and the
way we do it is basically the same no
matter who we are as well but it made me
think of I believe it was Stephen Jay
Gould the biologist that was something
affected I'm paraphrasing I'm not so
much disturbed by all the harm and
violence of man is visited upon himself
over the years but rather how many
geniuses and creative brains were lost
in those processes during him whether it
was genocide slavery all these things
how many created how many people had in
their blood in their DNA just never got
the opportunity and you touch them at
that it really is that spark is not so
much being born with the genius it's the
process of overcoming adversity of
dealing with setbacks of believing in
themselves of innovation and some
support ecosystems and so that seems to
be a prevalent demon oh this is this is
fundamentally important I need something
that's worse than that in a way
everybody can create I don't care if
you're male female black white straight
gay trans whatever you have this innate
ability to be creative and as a species
we depend on our creative ability all of
our creative abilities to survive and
thrive and right now we live in this
society which has this myth of genius
which by the way is generally code for a
white man and we have all these other
people with creative ability who are
being oppressed and by oppressing them
we are diminishing our own potential as
species so it's very important
to recognize the innate creative ability
in everybody and to nurture that because
we all benefit from it ultimately agree
and in your opinion what it's what order
ways that we can actually do the
netiquette sort of get more societal and
political but I mean we have to get rid
of this method betrayed your genius the
Unicorn they did this the OSIS and you
see it actually Ashley's book is
excellent about Elon Musk and you see it
there that you've got ostensibly a book
about one guy who's achieving incredible
things but there are tens of thousands
of people working with him and he may be
the most important among them but he's
nothing without them and so you know my
crusade is is really to have us all
recognize their own humanity and our own
potential and help one another develop
that that's how we slay the myth of the
you know the one white guy who's a
genius who can do something that we
can't do it's just not true well I think
Mozart Muppets
I smell succumb I do and I also forgot
to mention Kevin now is actually a
native austenite and spends most but not
in a book but not lives in Austin since
most of his time as understand driving
up and down mopac to make it more
crowded but but you are you are here now
in and out of curiosity what's keeping
you busy these days I'm writing my next
book I have a interest in a few Austin
basements company I travel the world
speaking I just got back from Monte
Carlo which was lovely but it's better
to be home I have a great time and I'm
living the kind of the Austin dream and
if you're not from here
I'm supposed to tell you to go home but
actually I welcome you and I want you to
stay this is it this is one of the best
places on earth well sir
shameless plug for our tomorrow I want
to move on any line must for a few
minutes and I will confess as I confess
to a show that have a man crush on on
Elon and he's he's actually it's been
quite a quite a few number of hours I
here in the Texas capital lobbying for
the removal of a why I shouldn't get
into this on c-span that was political I
could probably get into it but I do want
to thank actually for joining us today
actually has some ties to Texas as I
recall so we'll give him some Street
credibility but his book is a fantastic
really in my opinion the only real
in-depth look at Elon Musk that I think
Elon is permitted or maybe now in
hindsight that would not permit but
we'll find a little bit more about that
but a fantastic read not only in the
Elon but into his background of course
and it's a sort of a biography but
really touches on more in my opinion the
entire innovation process and what he
sees for our future and believe it or
not most of our a lot of our future will
be dictated by this guy and I guess to
Kevin's point and yet another rich white
guy but but but in my opinion he lends a
little bit special and so I wanted to
dive in a little bit into that so
actually if you would I guess also start
with a cliche question what was the the
inspiration of the impetus for for
writing the book sure ah well so I've
been a technology reporter in Silicon
Valley for about 15 years now and in a
lot of ways this would have been a
really unlikely book for me to do
Elon was he was never a guy was not
interested in he seemed like you know
I've had these beat companies that I
would cover
regularly and Elon seemed to me like the
guy who was frankly sort of a blowhard
in Silicon Valley he would always
promise these fantastic things and they
always seem to take much longer than
Benny said to deliver and they were very
expensive and and then around like 2012
it just really it changed for me he for
people who don't follow what he does
SpaceX is it's not a space tourism
company it's more of a commercial
satellite launching company they docked
with the International Space Station and
really replaced the Space Shuttle and
and gave us a chance to get to space
instead of depending on the Russians
Tesla his electric car company came out
with the Model X sedan and escapades the
Tesla's first car which was
seeing as more of a toy for rich people
the Model S still caters to rich people
but it was viewed as maybe the best car
ever built and even people in Detroit
who were very skeptical of Tesla gave
the company credit for that and then
Solar City is his third company where
he's chairman and it's a solar panel
company in and it filed for a public
offering and became the United States's
largest installer solar panels so this
all happened in a span of about three
months and I thought you know as far as
industrialists go I mean there's really
even though he still has a lot to prove
there's nobody in history that's been in
those diverse of fields and accomplished
that much in that span of time and so I
did a cover story on him and and I ended
up I went to the Tesla factory which is
in Silicon Valley and then I went to
SpaceX rocket factory which is in Los
Angeles and that blew me away as well
that we're sort of in this time when
we're told we can't really make anything
to the United States so this guy was
building these really complicated things
in the most expensive cities in the
United States and you know it's not for
show that SpaceX rocket Factory is about
four miles from LAX and I thought they
would be had making one rocket but their
mass producing rockets with thousands of
people and so he kind of blew me away
and then Elon I had a chance to
interview him for this cover story and
you just it was much more interesting
that I thought I'd sort of pecked him
there's more of a techno utopian kind of
guy but he you know he was very
authentic he was a good interview he was
surprisingly down-to-earth in a lot of
ways he didn't have a lot of handlers
around him it was just me and him and so
I've been looking for a book to do and I
thought this was this was the guy he was
he was running counter to so much of
this stuff in Silicon Valley which is
quick hits entertainment consumer
services and like here was a guy who is
building stuff again and that's what I
was interested in
all right backtrack a moment how did you
originally pitch it to him over the
initial conversations like those were
difficult so I'd done the cover story
and we had we had a pretty good rapport
kind of coming out of that he has he
tends to have kind of a controversial
relationship with journalists and but we
got along okay and so I went to him and
I said look I think I'd like to maybe do
a book on you just to feel him out and
see what kind of response you would get
and he said sort of comically that he
was going to write his own book even
though he's running three companies at
the same time and and so I took that as
unlikely but he definitely brushed me
off and then I took a risk I went and I
sold the book in New York a couple
months later and I thought that what
really forces him that if I sold the
book and I came back to him and told him
that that he would end up cooperating so
we had this big meeting at Tesla on one
Saturday and so Tesla's office their
factories in Fremont California which is
on the edge of Silicon Valley in their
offices in Palo Alto and this is
Saturday and these days in Silicon
Valley to be totally honest most people
do not work on the weekends like they
did back you know 20 30 years ago but at
Tesla the parking lot was full of cars
that I walked in and he's got everybody
there working on Saturday and in typical
Elon fashion he made me wait about an
hour for our meeting and and he comes in
and the first day he sits down and you
sort of made small talk and I said Laos
is so impressive you've got all these
people here on a Saturday and the first
thing out of his mouth was it's funny
that you say that I was just about to
send an email to everyone telling them
how soft we've gotten and I expect more
people to be here on the weekend and and
it's tutoring a little bit on Jeff Bezos
yeah yeah so we sort of got off to a
rough start and then you know I told him
I sold the book and again he told me he
was not going to cooperate so that was
there was sort of this moment where I
decided can I do this or not and I
decided to go ahead and I spent the next
18 months interviewing about 200 people
ex-employees of Tesla SpaceX Elon also
co-founded PayPal so all the PayPal
people I thought its ex-girlfriends I
found his worst enemies all that stuff
and after 18 months that seemed to wear
him down and one day I was at home and I
got a call from Elon Musk in the evening
he was on my caller ID and and he
decided that we should have a chat it
out but he ended up cooperating with the
book after that so I interviewed him for
about eight months and I got access to
the companies and folded that into what
I had already done and I don't want to
give too much away the book this really
is I mean this is the only access I've
seen like this to Geelong and so now
that we're here the books been out at
the New York Times best seller what is
has there been any feedback from Elon
pertaining directly or bad good or
indifferent yeah it's been a bit of a
roller coaster he so he was not a lot he
wanted to see the book before it was
published which I would not did you
forget this the cover photo he should
thank me for that photo because it's a
very flattering that is what anything in
front of it that is the SpaceX engine
okay yeah I'm sorry you were saying well
so he so he didn't get to he wanted to
read the book he actually wanted to put
footnotes in the book at one point and I
would not let him do that show yeah but
I did let him see the book before he
didn't have to buy it on Amazon I gave
it to him about ten days before it came
out and and so his initial reaction you
know I with this very Elon passion I
woke up one morning and I had about 50
emails waiting for me he had started
reading the book at 3:30 a.m. yet this
guy never sleeps he like works 24 hours
a day just about and he'd been going
paragraphs like paragraph through the
book but to be honest I mean most of
that was it was actually it was like a
mix of good and bad but nothing too
controversial and then and then a couple
days went past and then he came back and
he said look I think the book is is
accurate he gave me a 95% accuracy
rating that's pretty good for me like
for Elon that's very very good
and he and he said he said it was well
done and then then the press got a hold
of the book and they started sort of
building up some of the more mostly
focusing on what a tough boss he is and
he could be very hard on his employees
and it was funny once you saw the
reaction was he saw that reaction it was
very strange then he had a bigger
reaction after that and so he's been a
bit upset about those parts you touch on
a lot of his working relationships with
with the people that have been with him
early on at what it was PayPal startups
before that his brother all the way
through SpaceX Solar City you know I
hate to make comparisons but you know
we're talking about these tech giants as
that Kevin alluded to what similarities
or differences does he have for maybe
the jet phases to Steve Jobs those kinds
of guys huh yeah it seems to me to stand
out to be a little bit different but
what's your opinion I think he is
differen
he's definitely different to me but
there are there are comparisons you can
make it sort of like Steve Jobs he he's
running the company but he gets down to
sort of the product layer of things I
mean he is deciding I would walk around
with them at Tesla's design studio and
he's looking at the wind the the
sun-visors of the car and and it in this
very again this very Elon way he you'd
be like this Sun visors crap I want the
best Sun Visor in the world you know
coke get me that and and so and things
like the funny the door handles on the
model last they sort of retract in and
go flush with the car I mean that is
absolutely something that Elon wanted
and that his engineers fought him on and
and that he because they knew it would
be difficult to do and that he insisted
on and it's become well it did have
problems with the clients become sort of
one of its signature things and so you
know he seems to have an eye for these
things SpaceX is exactly the same way
this is a guy who taught himself
aerospace by reading textbooks at the
Cabana at the Hard Rock Cafe Hotel in
Las Vegas and and he actually makes
sometimes good sometimes bad decisions
about the design of the Rockets and so
he goes down to that level I think I
mean I
in the book I probably draw more
parallels to somebody like in Edison and
mostly for the reasons you outline I
mean this is a guy who's assembled
engineering armies that's really what
he's good at is finding is getting huge
quantities of people at Tesla you're now
talking about around upwards of 10,000
people at SpaceX 5,000 people he's
getting these very bright ambitious
capable people to essentially dedicate
their lives to what he wants them to do
and and you it's they're very inventive
companies they're able to take ideas and
actually productize them and I think
that's probably his biggest
accomplishment and then I think the one
thing that like Jeff Bezos and some of
these other guys he obviously thinks
long-term and is not tries not to get
caught up in what investors on Wall
Street care about from quarter to
quarter he's with SpaceX in particular
he wants to create a colony on Mars and
that sort of a tough thing to sell on
Wall Street and so he's been very
determined not to take SpaceX public and
and so that's something you have to
convince both your employees well that's
a good idea and everybody else and so he
has a little bit of everyone I would say
having interviewed most of these people
in Silicon Valley I would say he is more
capable across a broader set of thing so
business strategy product design
marketing very few people are adept at
doing bits in each one of those areas
and he LAN makes plenty of mistakes but
he's actually quite good at be played to
the high level across all those parts as
I understand it everyone at SpaceX is at
a compulsory watching party at the
corporate headquarters today on Sunday
so we do want to thank Elon for putting
the SpaceX facility in Brownsville Texas
and just one last question kind of
tangent but he mentioned this to me
earlier today you were on a flight from
San Francisco with a guy reading the
book
and talked to the first the happy
coincidence and then what do you decided
to do because of you that's funny
that's like paper I don't want to over
something but I read this guy it was it
was interesting he was reading the book
and then he told me you know I sort of
tapped him on the shoulder near the end
of the flight I said I I wrote that book
and he's I he said I mean I've gotten a
few emails like this he was a guy who
was kind of mid-career and he decided he
was going to quit his current job and he
had to go do something that was more
risky he'd been in sales and he wanted
to go to a kind of he identified to
startups in Silicon Valley that he
thought were doing something more
radical that's what he wanted to do and
I mean it's been funny since the book
came out especially with Twitter sure
you see the same thing where you get
this wonderful feedback from people
actually read the book and and I there's
these people who this is sort of what I
wanted to do too is you've got MBAs and
people that were going to law school and
they're all I don't know maybe they'll
curse me in a few years but they were
chucking it in and wanted to usually get
a job at SpaceX or go back and get an
engineering degree so I don't know some
of that is pleasant is rewarding alright
well I Kevin his book does such a
wonderful job of weaving together so
many multiple narratives about the
process the individuals behind it but
more importantly the process and the
life experience of course Elon is a
penultimate example of that let me just
put it out to you both though I was
particularly thinking of Ilan's you know
he had almost a lethal case of oh I
guess it was a lethal case of malaria
lost a child as a young as a young man
but those types of things and Kevin you
talked about some of the similar
problems or similar setbacks with some
folks but I'm going to get you both in
conversation sort of about that process
particularly overcoming the obstacle the
setback it seems to be
not really genius but that we're coming
adversity that persistence that seems to
be the common theme and I want to get
you both to talk a little bit more in
depth about that I mean I talk in the
book my book a lot about the importance
of passion and in a passion is a pretty
one of the most powerful sources of
personal energy that we have and it's
difficult to be passionate about
something superficial you think about
yourself what are you passionate about
you you're probably not passionate about
you know I don't know your drapes right
you have a passion about your children
or your family or there's some higher
purpose that motivates you and what you
see with creative people and most
successful ones is they are passionate
about something very meaningful and one
of the things I read it Elon Musk is one
of the most important innovators alive
today and the reason is what he's
passionate about
he's probably of all the billionaires in
the world he's probably the one that's
least interested in money that's the
first thing and he he was practically
broke a few years ago actually does a
very good job of explaining this because
he made some money put it all into his
businesses why did he do that well he
kind of gets it right we we depend on
technology for our survival as a species
it's made it's a very successful species
there will come a point when this planet
is not big enough for the human race
anymore there are one of the things that
my job is there kind of a futurist I say
often is the future is actually very
easy to predict it's very hard to
believe one of the things I can predict
about the future is at some point
probably not that far from now we
actually do have to live on another
planet if we're going to continue to
thrive and grow so Musk's phrase for
this is we have to become an
interplanetary species that's why he
wants to go colonize Mars now that
sounds incredibly unbelievable right but
it's also incredibly predictable it's
true we're going to need to solve this
problem so I think what you see in great
creators is the ability to overcome
terrible obstacles because they're
passionate
something greater and musk epitomizes
that to me I mean I think there are the
biggest risks there Elon Musk is he may
die very young because he's working
incredibly hard and it's not good for
his health but what the reason he's
doing that is because he has this higher
purpose you may not agree with it but
that's motivating him to work longer
hours to work harder I think it's one of
the reasons he gets mad at employees who
want to take one Sunday a year off or
something you know ridiculous like that
so you know that that's what I see as
the reason that some people are able to
you know suffer the terrible experience
of like losing a child or rebound from a
really bad illness or you know do some
other crazy things that people like him
do it's because there's something more
important than themselves it's driving
them forward as well yeah I mean I would
totally agree that there's things about
Elon that are both refreshing and and I
think sort of probably would be
disturbing to most people I mean I don't
think most people would want to live
their life quite like he does completely
to Kevin's point Elon has this is a kid
he as a kid he by the time he was 14 he
may have read every science fiction book
ever penned and and where some kids
would sort of revel in the fantasies of
those things I mean he took this is sort
of his life's calling and internalized
it and decided yeah I mean I am the guy
who will go do this and he lives his
life really on a level of like nobody
I've ever seen he's very utilitarian
it's basically I have a finite amount of
time on this earth that I'm going to
maximize my time going after my goals
and you know if that means that I have
to be pretty rough on my employees if
that means my family life is going to
implode if that means I have to lose
every dollar then so be it when he sold
PayPal he made 220 million dollars and I
don't think there's anyone near here who
would sacrifice every last penny which
is what he did he burned through the
entire 220 million dollars building
rockets in electric cars it's
essentially like taking all of your
money and just lie
on fire those are the two worst things
you could possibly do if you wanted to
keep your money and you know he in in
2008 both companies are going bankrupt
he's going through a divorce
he's lost a child and he basically
through sheer force of will and
chicanery gets through this period and I
think there's kind of very few people
that would have walked out of that let
alone end up with ten thirteen billion
dollars a few years later and and so I
mean that's why I wrote the book to me
he's he's sort of passionate on on a
level that you rarely experienced there
was a champion your book they reminded
me that seem to graduate with Dustin
Hoffman I have one word for you Benjamin
Rockets but how to fly a horse it
literally does take you on a tour de
force of 50,000 years of innovation the
Elan musk story almost fifty years of a
remarkable remarkable rise to to future
shaping and wanted to be well do a
magnificent job of the past I want to
touch on the future as compared with
Kevin just mentioned as my last question
Elon Musk and some of you may know this
is part of a group called the long now
foundation and many others are involved
with it Jeb base is one of them but your
book touches on some of their budding of
heads I should say but one of their
projects which is going to sound strange
probably the strangest flying to Mars is
a ten thousand year clock that will be
self-winding and so perpetuating that
will exist for 10,000 years simply to
remind us that we need to think more
long-term to think more into the future
as we once as a species and it will
actually be housed here in Texas and Van
Horn and West Texas in a cave but where
do you see the future of creativity the
future of innovation its and then all
this is Kevin alluded to it's in a story
like Elon but whatever what it seems or
or
or evolutions as you see coming down the
pike and how we create yes how we great
how we how we foster their creativity we
incubator so one of the really
interesting things about the human
propensity to create is how it keeps
accelerating so you look at the first
50,000 years of human history so from
you know the the arrival of modern human
beings to today and it was like about
ten thousand years ago only that we we
started like looking after animals and
domesticating animals was another 5,000
years before we've got agriculture at
all rising emerged about that time you
know now we've gone through like seven
models of iPhone in the last four years
an Elon Musk is you know got
self-driving cars all over the world and
it's flying rockets to space and back
right so what's driving the acceleration
and there are two things one is
population there are far more of us now
than there were five thousand years ago
and everybody is creative so the more
people creating the more things get
creative is the other one is we're
building on the knowledge of previous
generations and we are taking advantage
of the innovations of previous
generations so if you take that to the
Future we're going to be at about 10
billion people there in 2100 that's sort
of more than twice as many people as we
have now or something that's a lot of
creating they're going to be benefiting
from all these innovations we're able to
communicate with one another globally in
a way that we weren't before so will we
have unprecedented creative ability but
the other things go back to something I
said at the beginning it's a tremendous
social progress we are seeing the
ability of more and more different you
know types of people to contribute
creatively that's going to accelerate
our creative ability and we're raising
up in parts of the world where people
have not been able to create very much
before in China in Africa in India so
it's an incredibly bright
for the human race actually which you
don't get to hear very often right
because it's it's so much easier to be
pessimistic the zombie apocalypse is
nearly here things terrible you know and
that's some bad leg traffic but that's
not that's not the whole story
well then I'm going to leave that on an
optimistic note so that's a good note to
end on Kevin Ashton how to fly a horse
Ashley Vance Elon Musk and his
magnificent story please help me and
thank him the two of them I'd like to
turn it on them to the to the audience
for some questions and answers there's a
microphone here in the center if you
wouldn't mind queuing up there it please
direct your question to either the two
the two authors or both of them if you'd
like to and we'll try to to give us on
schedule
[Music]
Kevin my question is when you look at
people who have had aha moments do you
see any pattern that goes around that
that makes them what might leave them up
to that moment or what they do when they
have that moment sure I mean and that
the great question that the pattern is
they don't actually have a whole moments
okay so the aha moment if you're not
familiar with it is the idea that and we
mentioned Mozart that there are Mozart
is is alone in a good mood and suddenly
a symphony appears in his head and he
writes it down and he's done and one of
things to wear in the book is that is
the myth based on a letter that is a
forgery now we've known it's a forgery
for about 150 years but you still see it
in academic papers about creativity as
if it were true right people like the
men the reality is step-by-step process
someone with a lot of skill a lot of
experience trying and failing until they
come to this wonderful feeling of all I
finally finished something
it's like completing a jigsaw puzzle
right the ten thousand piece may be the
one that feels the best but you have to
put the others in first so that's the
truth about the aha moment it's a great
feeling that comes at the end of a very
long series of steps
so this is a question for both authors
last night I went to go see the new
Steve Jobs movie and it was brilliant
but there's kind of a theme for people
like Steve Jobs or people like Elon Musk
or Kanye West who try to change the
world they seem to be [ __ ]
just public television is there a way to
change the world without being an
[ __ ] is there such thing as a
pinellas an [ __ ] we get it three
times okay
yes other way Kanye was the steve job
that the only time they're gonna be the
same sense i mean i get asked this
question why i think Dylan has this he
seems to rub people the wrong way
because he has what I described in the
book is a strange sort of empathy he's
you know he's not very empathetic
towards what's going on in his employees
daily lives if they come to him and say
they're you know they have to miss some
work function because their kids going
to go to a soccer game he really doesn't
care about that at all and your puppy
may well get fired because of it he when
we would talk he would sort of honestly
he would break down almost completely in
tears when he would start talking about
building a colony on Mars and how
important this was for mankind and and I
mean he he seems to viscerally feel you
know the the peril of the human species
from some kind of unforeseen event and
so he's wired I think in such a
different way that it's hard to draw
these huge parallels I think I mean
since Steve Jobs there's been this
tendency to sort of glorify people that
are Church and are getting things done
although you know I've in it I've
interviewed most of these guys and in
the valley and there doesn't seem to be
a there does seem to be a propensity to
be really hard on people and I pushed
them forward but I would say like Gandhi
Jesus Abraham Lincoln there are there
are plenty of examples of people who
changed the world who have had a great
charm and great social skill
that's the first thing the second thing
I'd say is you know I'd sadly you're
talking about a bunch of privileged
white men and privilege can can make you
less than polite sometimes which is
something we have to sense the third
thing I'd say is I've had I don't know
the opposite of privileges I've had the
misfortune of working for quite a large
number of what I know the politically
correct word is that non charming people
and many of them were not changing the
world in any way I think there's a
proliferation of non charming people in
the world do it but I would I would say
it's a coincidence well to it very
diplomatic yes yes sir
okay yeah another question for both of
you about Elon Musk can you talk a
little bit about how they are how he put
together his team for Tesla specifically
how many how many people that he
actually hired himself you know
interview and hire and then just the
follow-up question after you got all
these emails from him having read the I
guess the manuscript of the book did you
make any changes so I can add I can
answer the second one quickly I mean the
book was done by the time it was already
printed by the time he read it so no I
didn't in there there was nothing
factually that I would have to correct
the on the second question I don't know
if it's going to be as fulfilling
because there's sort of a different
story for Tesla and SpaceX Tesla was
actually founded by two other gentlemen
other than Elon Elon was the original
money man and so they were really
responsible for hiring the initial team
and you know I would say what was
remarkable about that was that it was a
very small group of people on the order
of about 40 engineers in Silicon Valley
who had been the valley have never done
a car before so there are all these gear
heads that were kind of waiting for this
opportunity to arise for an interesting
car company that show up and so they
ditch their jobs and they went in there
they worked crazy hours and it was a mix
of sort of middle aged engineers and
guys straight out of Stanford who were
solar car aficionados and so they dug in
and at SpaceX
that is the Alon's baby and I he gets
full credit for
he interviewed every single employee up
through about the first two thousand and
he would cold call he would call people
at Stanford's in their aerospace
division he would call the professors
and say who are your best guys then he
would call the kids in their dorm room
and say I've got a space company I want
you to come join and they say no this is
not Elon Musk cause he was already
pretty famous from PayPal by that time
and no one believed there he's like yes
I am come down he went to space Braves
out in the desert that he would chat up
these kids that whoever seemed
interesting he'd say why don't you come
by and do an interview in the book I
talk a lot about I go through some of
these things and then also you know his
interview process is sort of famous for
being very torturous and and and so he
was very good at finding what do you
look for it was not he doesn't like to
pay people much money so he does not go
to Harvard and Yale and get the best
people he tries to find people at
technical universities engineering
schools who have built something in high
school or in college who worked on a
team who helps you project through to
fruition and that's pretty much what he
always looked for all right Kevin
anything to enter this no I most of what
I not that alone I got from Ashley's
book excellent and from reading his
emails okay last question sir please
Ashley
how important do you feel or did you get
into the study of psychedelic
experiences in terms of Ellen's idea
generation an impetus for I prelog you
know I mean I know Steve Jobs experiment
it was psychedelics as far as I know
Elon loves to go to Burning Man and goes
you know I dug into this pretty hard as
far as I know if Elon I never found any
conclusive proof that that he he's not
he's not much of a drinker he's not much
of he sort of likes to go for the
experience of it all he does go to
Burning Man every year spends quite a
bit of time there he builds sorting
paste I want to build an art car that he
gets to drive around and he likes to
dance and all that stuff but I never I
would just be making something up if I
told you because I never found
a conclusive proof one way or the other
yeah thanks nothing's delicious well as
you must even known for coming to the
20th anniversary by the way the Texas
book coastal Hills correct to say that
20 years we typically don't do any
business book programming I had the idea
this year to commemorate the 25th
anniversary of the art of the deal by
the great Donald Trump but he was busy
so we're never forget him but when you
do read these - these are really
engrossing in varying gulping books and
it almost makes you feel like you're in
a fiction world because they're so
engaging but then you realize that these
are in fact real stories of real
inventors really inventors real thinkers
and real creative thought leaders and
you imagine that these are actually the
folks that are crafting your future so
both fantastic reads I recommend them
please join us at table 21
after you grab a copy and I want to
thank you all again for joining us
please thank again Ashley Vance Kevin
Ashton
[Applause]
I also put a box of kind bars there on
the stage from one of our sponsors is
anybody else into the jokes excuse me
they are both long
[Applause]